no one had ever taken an IMAX camera to
the summit of Everest I don't think
anyone ever thought it was a wise idea
but we worked with the IMAX corporation
and got the camera produced from 40
kilos to 20 kilos and it was manageable
load for a Sherpa as the leader of the
Everest IMAX team and the
cinematographer and the co-director we
started up that mountain we wanted to
make a film about four people reaching
the summit on a sunny day and on may 9th
and 10th in came this storm I changed
our film this film have risked the the
feature film for me has its origin in
1996 here my friends are following in
the very footsteps of history something
beyond the power of words to describe
working title films reached out to me
because of my experience not only on the
mountain that year but as a filmmaker so
today's a day huh I'd filmed on it many
other times and they wanted to know
what's it like to be on the mountain
it's a little-known fact but the reason
this film looks so authentic and
glorious and majestic is because we took
a film team to the summit for Universal
and working title films whether it was
the IMAX film in 1996 or seeing this on
an IMAX screen you feel much closer to
the experience you feel much more
immersed in the experience I felt I was
stuck on the mountain during that storm
seeing the film in IMAX on the big
screen and with the sound system it
gives it scale it gives it size the team
got it right and I'm really proud of
this film I love this film
you